everything you see in Disney's new Lion
King exists in a delicate balance with
its animated ancestor yes like all the
studio's remakes is connected in a great
cinematic circle of life but is it still
a roaring good time like the original
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers I'm Jan and
today I'm explaining the biggest 14
differences between the new Lion King
movie and the 1994 classic I'm also
kicking off a new giveaway so subscribe
hit the bell and leave a comment about
the movie for a chance to win some
spoilers ahead so take care if you
haven't seen it yet there's one line
that I especially love in the animation
that doesn't make it into the new movie
and that's I'm surrounded by deer which
scarce is about his hyena cronies while
it's a shame that bit of dialogue
doesn't appear in the remake there is a
good reason for it you see in the
reworked story the hyenas are generally
much less stupid and much more menacing
than they are in the 1994 film so their
part involves a lot less slapstick we
don't lack it all you started it look at
you guys
well wonder we're dangling at the bottom
of the food chain director Jon Favreau
felt the broad comedy of the animated
hyenas wouldn't gel with the new films
photorealism and more grounded nature so
don't expect any scenes of hyenas
crashing into masses of thorny bushes or
rolling around laughing as they say a
fascist name over and over but although
those kinds of shenanigans are out and
top hyena Shenzi especially is more
scary there's still some comic relief
from her fellow hyenas as easy and
kumari who've been given new African
names instead of the original Eden bangs
I another big change which ties in with
how the new hyenas are portrayed is scar
song be prepared before the movie came
out there were rumors that the fan
favorite song hadn't made the final cut
however while it definitely is in the
film it's undergone quite a
transformation and is now performed as a
mix of speak singing with some regular
singing by chiwetel ejiofor who voices
scar when I am teeth the mighty will be
free to take whatever they want and the
new version of the iconic villain tune
is significantly sure
water than the 1994 version that's
because many of the original verses just
don't fit the story anymore now the
hyena characters are no longer as
dim-witted so Ghana scores many in
varied ways of calling the hyenas
brainless idiots like some and gone two
of the numerous times he has to explain
his plan until they eventually
understand it we're gonna kill it what
remains the same though is the song's
chorus and the idea that when scar is
king the hyenas reward will be a full
belly why eat one meal when you can be
feasting the rest of your lives another
part of this sequence that's been
discarded are these intensely colored
scenes that resemble a volcanic
hellscape and the shots of scar looking
on as row upon row of hyenas do step
past imagery which was actually based on
footage of Hitler and the Nazis the
reason those moments have been given the
chop is because the new film is going
for a more naturalistic approach when it
comes to the animals look and behavior
as the voice of the animated scar Jeremy
Irons gave the villainous line a
wickedly arch and wonderfully outrageous
theatrical tone well I like the surprise
Simba it's to die for
which at times reminds me of George
Saunders sleekly voiced villain Shere
Khan in Disney's 1960s classic The
Jungle Book
Bravo Bravo and thank you for detaining
my victim lots of Lion King fans really
love ions as a memorable take on scar so
is a tough role for any actor to step
into but sure as hell Ejiofor has really
put his own stamp on the character
giving his scar and more Shakespearean
interpretation Mufasa and Simba are gone
which means I am your key which fits
well with the story as Hamlet was one of
the inspirations for the original film
but it's not just scars voice and manner
that's changed his appearance has also
been given an update now Simba's evil
uncle looks much more battle-worn
with
numerous marks and scars all over his
face a piece missing from one of his
ears
a shabby a Mane and his signature scar
over his left eye looks painfully real
like the original movie the remakes Pam
grunts whoo moan have some of the best
comedic moments in the story but in the
2019 version Disney have gone even more
messy with the humor this is the place
you're fighting for this is my home is
it behind that terrifying rock talk
about your fixer-upper Seth Rogen and
Billy Eichner who voiced the warthog a
meerkat duo give a fantastic performance
nailing the jokes that make a
reappearance from the first film what's
the matter nothing what's the matter
with you very slow but they were also
given a lot of leeway to improvise lines
and the scene of Timon and Pumbaa
teaching Simba to eat grubs with all the
other animals has been cleverly updated
if you want to live with us you have to
eat like us crunchy they're local yeah
Oh are they they're from right there
Rogen and Eichner riffing on Hakuna
Matata is also very funny and there's an
interesting meta moment when this time
around the uncensor this joke from the
1994 animation
[Music]
not in front of the kids sorry in
another very self-aware moment the
remake assumes that much of its audience
has already watched the original film
so when Pumbaa and Timon mentioned
Hakuna Matata to Simba they're shocked
he hasn't heard of it's already after me
[Music]
most people get a bigger reaction when
we say look for okay which reminded me a
lot of the joke in Aladdin when the
genie makes a big neon applause sign
appear after he sings friends like me
Disney even pokes fun at the Lion King
sacred circle of life idea and an extra
scene added to the new movie where pump
run Timon make the case to Simba that
the circle of life doesn't actually
exist instead it's more of a meaningless
line of indifference kid that's not a
song that's propaganda when Simba and
Nala need to sneak past the hyena guards
to get to Pride Rock both movies put a
musical feast on the menu as a way
around their problem all we need to do
is find something that's like big and
juicy
why they were looking at me in the
animation as Timon presented his pal
Pumbaa as a tasty treat to distract the
hyenas the meerkat did a song and dance
routine to the Hawaiian War chart which
was also a little nod to the Enchanted
Tiki Room at Disney's theme parks where
the tune plays in the new film however
cool is out and another delicious Disney
Easter egg is in yes this time - moans
kyun of choice is the much-loved beauty
in the beasts track be our guest it is
with deepest pride and greatest pleasure
that we're out live presents your dinner
it's really funny hearing Timon perform
a short version of Lumias famous opening
lines before he runs off screaming with
Bumba as they're chased by the hyenas oh
and when Timon puts on his best French
accent to do this bit it reminded me of
this moment and the animated version of
can you feel the love tonight just sweet
character I don't when Beyonce was cast
in the new Lion King many people saw
that knowledge role will get a lot more
development
and in the final film she discuss a few
more lines and scenes including her
escape from scar her journey home with
Simba and then there's her rallying cry
are you with me lions as the pride get
in formation to battle the movies Big
Bad still not only adds up to touch more
time on screen for Nala than she got in
the animation and overall it feels less
developed compared say to how the
live-action Aladdin beefed up Jasmine's
rolled making him more active and
fleshing out her backstory as well as
Beyonce's gorgeous take on can you feel
the love tonight she does get a brand
new musical moment in the film though
which I'll talk about later and on top
of that there's her new Lion King
inspired album the gift where she's
described as a love letter to Africa in
the 90s classic after a hyena calls
Pumbaa a pig the animated warthog
launches into a speech made up of
popular quotes from famous movies he
kicks things off with Robert De Niro's
unforgettable line from Martin
Scorsese's taxi driver hey who's the pig
are you talking to me they call him the
pig are you talking to me the gun are
you talking to me and finishes up with a
hat tip to Sidney Poitier's electrifying
words from the 1960s oscar-winning in
the heat of the night powder in foriegn
hey call me in an update the new Lion
King drops the movie references and adds
a different comical scene which features
the hyenas calling Pumbaa chubby after
which the warthog sends a body positive
message to his bullies I will not be
made to feel ashamed of Who I am he says
before chasing them off in complete
contrast with the vivid colors and more
stylized look of the animation the new
film has gone for a photorealistic look
that's absolutely mind-blowing the
digitally created locations and animals
are so astoundingly natural-looking that
it's hard to believe you're not actually
watching real wildlife on screen apart
from the fact of course that these
creatures talk and sing but the remakes
focus on photo realism doesn't just
affect the way the animals look it also
has a huge effect on how the animals act
the human-like behavior and facial
expressions we saw in the 1994 movie are
largely gone in the new film replaced
with more natural animal
behavior so don't expect to see animals
pulling cheeky faces or making neck
cutting gestures
sobbing their hearts out piling their
claws swinging on vines lounging about
in vine hammocks or forming an animal
pyramid and those very human esque
eyebrows have also been given the chop a
number of film critics have said that
all this realism means the new film
loses some of the emotion of the
original now I don't remember people
having that same problem with Jon
Favreau's photo-real Jungle Book reboot
but maybe that speaks more to the place
the Lion King holds in the heart of many
fans or perhaps it's because that film
also featured a human actor on screen
either way if you want to enjoy the new
movie you'll likely need to just accept
less exaggerated facial expressions one
thing's for sure though it's absolutely
criminal how cute photo-real Simba is
several new songs have also been added
to the soundtrack but only one of them
features in the film proper that's
Beyonce's song spirit which we hear as
adult Simba and Nala run back to Pride
Rock together and that scene is actually
another little change from the animated
film where Simba makes the journey back
to the pride lands separately to Nala
the original film's composers Elton John
and Tim Rice also return to write a new
song called never too late which Jon
sings over the closing credits and
straight after that you'll hear he lives
in you which is about how even in death
Mufasa will always be with Simba the
song is part of both the Broadway show
of the Lion King as well as the movie
sequel Simba's pride and it's performed
and written by LeBeau M whose work on
the animations music was crucial in
creating it's unforgettable sound
there's also some more fascinating
changes in the remake that fix a number
of surprising goofs and mistakes in the
1994 animation that's in my next video
and I'll add a link here and in the
video description as soon as it's ready
now it's time for you to decide which
Lion King is better I've added a poll
where you can vote just tap in the top
of this video and after you've cast your
vote you'll be able to see the results
let me know what you think in the
comments below and subscribe to enter my
Lion King giveaway congratulations to
the winner of my stranger things
giveaway contact me via email from my
about page so I can
your prized tapleft for my next Lion
King video or tap write for another
video you're sure to like thanks for
watching and see you next time you pick
a movie lovers